okay so
today we're going to start talking about
meta reinforcement learning
uh we'll have three lectures on this
topic and this will be the first one
that covers
the basics
okay so for today we're going to start
talking about meta reinforcement
learning uh
we're going to cover the problem
statement um we're going to talk about
how block box methods and optimization
based methods can be translated to a
meta rl setting
uh
i think that a lot of the the content in
this lecture is
fairly straightforward it's mostly a
matter of basically taking the concepts
that we were thinking about before in
meta learning and trying to translate
them to a reinforcement learning setting
uh and so we'll cover also a lot of
really kind of examples of what this
looks like
um black box meta url methods are going
to come up in homework four you'll
basically get an opportunity to play
around with these methods
um and get a sense for for how they work
uh but they you
the kind of the primary part of homework
four is actually going to be on
learning to explore which is what we're
going to be covering
in lecture on monday next
week the goals of this lecture uh is to
provide an understanding of the meta rl
problem statement and a setup to help
you understand the basics of black box
meta are all methods and the basics and
some of the challenges that come up with
optimization based meta-rl algorithms
cool so
let's get started with the problem
statement um and for this we'll recap
briefly some of the things that we
covered in the previous lectures to
build up to the problem statement
so
in the past few lectures we've
introduced model free and model based
reinforcement learning methods and we
introduced them in within this kind of
general framework of a reinforcement
learning algorithm that iterates between
generating samples fitting some model to
estimate the return and using that to
improve the policy
for this box right here there's a few
different ways that you can estimate the
return one is to use monte carlo roll
outs of the policy
one is to fit a model that predicts the
cumulative returns
and a third is to fit a model of the
dynamics of the one step dynamics
which can also give you an estimate of
the return
if you
accumulate the the rollouts
using this one step model
uh and then once you have one of these
returns you can either uh one of these
estimates of the return you can either
use it to directly improve the policy
um use it to
compute the policy with regard to your
current queue function in a q learning
approach
or
optimize a policy by for example back
propagating gradients from a model into
the policy
so these are kind of a general class of
reinforcement learning approaches
um
beyond reinforcement learning and back
in the supervised learning setting we
also talked about these different
problem settings multi-test learning
problem setting a transfer learning
problem setting and the meta learning
problem
one key aspect of all these settings is
that we assume that the tasks must share
some structure
and kind of the key idea of
meta reinforcement learning of what
we'll talk about today is basically
taking this metal learning problem
and instead of using supervised learning
tasks each of the tasks will be
reinforcement learning tasks
so a reinforcement learning task
as we defined it before basically
corresponds to a markov decision process
where tasks may vary in terms of
different elements of that markov
decision process especially the dynamics
or the reward
um and so
what we'll talk about today is that meta
reinforcement learning will basically
just correspond to metal learning where
each of your tasks are these mdps
so
you're basically your goal will be
you're given some set of training tasks
or some set of training mdps
and then your goal will be to quickly
learn to solve a new mdp
based on your previous experience with
those other mdps
okay
so
that's kind of the high level overview
um
another view that we gave on the metal
learning problem
was one of basically mapping from
a training data set
and a test input
to a corresponding
prediction for that test input
so some sort of kind of function or
procedure that takes in the training set
takes as input the test input and makes
a prediction based on what it learned
from the training set
and
the way that this is learned is through
a data set of data sets
with this view we can kind of translate
this view
towards the meta reinforcement learning
problem statement by basically replacing
supervised learning
with reinforcement learning and then
translating that to the meta learning
setting
so in particular in reinforcement
learning our goal is not to map from x
to y is to map from states to actions
and the way that we do this is not
through input output pairs but
experience that has corresponding
rewards that indicate what kinds of
actions and states are good and what
kinds of states and actions are bad
now to translate this to
the setting where we want to learn many
tasks and ultimately learn a new task
quickly we can
kind of raise it up a level like we did
with supervised learning
in this case our goal will be
given a small amount of experience from
a new task
can we learn a policy from that
experience so given a small amount of
experience and the current state can we
predict an action
that will do well
in
that particular task
so you can view it as this mapping again
that takes is input some experience
and the current state and outputs the
action
and then the way that you learn this is
a setting where
you have a set of data sets and each
data set contains experience collected
for each of the tasks
okay so
this is kind of one way that we can use
the view the meta reinforcement learning
problem
and then
a core part of this problem of course is
to design what this procedure looks like
and how we're going to optimize this
procedure
and then also something that's different
than the standard meta supervised
learning problem is collecting
appropriate data how do we decide
we like now that we're in this
reinforcement learning setting we get to
control the data collection process so
we need to figure out how we should
collect this data
how we should collect kind of rollouts
from our policy and also
how we should collect kind of our meta
trading data as well
um this first part where we want to like
figure out how to collect data this is
kind of the problem of learning how to
explore for a task because collecting
this data is exploring for that task in
a way that allows you to solve that task
and so this part is is what we're going
to focus on in the next lecture for
monday today we're just going to think
about designing these
learning procedures and optimizing them
with reinforcement learning
okay
so
as a kind of
kind of instantiating example for this
in meta reinforcement learning let's say
the different tasks correspond to
navigating different mazes
so ultimately what we'd like to be able
to do is given a small amount of
experience in a new maze that we haven't
seen before
can we learn how to solve and solve that
maze essentially and allow us to
navigate to the goal position in that
maze
so in particular what this is showing is
this is showing some trajectories in the
maze where you're exploring the maze and
so forth and then given this experience
in the maze if you're then kind of
reinstantiated at this point you want
your policy to be able to directly go to
the goal and directly navigate that maze
so this is what you this is kind of
equivalent the equivalent view shot
learning problem in a reinforcement
learning setting
it's view shot reinforcement learning
this is what we want to be able to
accomplish at meta test time
and the way that we can go about
accomplishing this is by
training on lots of other mazes or lots
of other tasks
so we can learn how to quickly
explore and navigate a number of
different phases
so that when we're then given a new maze
at meta test time we can quickly solve
it
any questions on how this works
so the data for each task there would be
multiple trajectories
from that task or one episode
or is it multiple episodes or one
episode from each task yeah that's a
good question so
um
there's two different variants of the
meta reinforcement learning problem
one all referred to as the episodic
variant where you basically have k
trajectories that you're trying to learn
from
and
one i'll call the online variant which
your data now just contains k time steps
within that task
so you can consider either of these
or
some or i mean or something in between
basically but yeah you're either trying
to learn from a small amount of kind of
time steps or a small amount of
trajectories in both cases it's a small
amount of experience
different problem formulations will
consider different variants of the
problem
there's also a question in the chat
that's asking
when we fit a model to measure the
reward
what is the reward is it the policy or
the reward of the policy
um so the
a q function will be estimating the
cumulative reward of a certain policy
so this is given by q pi for example
um
then something like a model based
approach will be learning to predict the
next state and also the reward for that
current
state action index state
so it kind of depends on the
um on the problem setting or on the
approach
okay
so that's the meta rl problem
we'll talk about black box approaches if
there aren't any more questions on the
problem
okay
so
for black box meta rl approaches we can
basically translate all the ideas that
we had for black box metal learning to
this reinforcement learning setting
where we're going to be training a
neural network to take as input a data
set as well as your current state and
output the next action
now one of the things we talked about in
black box metal learning is that
typically when you have some data
d train there's no kind of natural
ordering of that data set so
there's kind of you may also you may
want to kind of process that data in a
permutation invariant way
but in reinforcement learning um
the data does actually have temporal
structure
so one very common approach for
processing this data is to use some sort
of recurrent network that process the
data sequentially
and specifically what this looks like is
basically you roll out this recurrent
network
everything up until the current time
step is basically the training data for
that task
this is uh and this training data
includes states actions and rewards
and you basically pass in that data as
it becomes available so
once you take action a1 for example from
state s1 then you actually after you
take that action you observe the reward
and also the next state so you pass in
that next date and that reward that you
just received as input to your recurrent
policy
and predict the next action
okay
now
one question uh
for you is
how is this approach different
from simply just running reinforcement
learning
using our current policy
uh and feel free to answer in chat or by
raising your hand and specifically i
have at least two things in mind with
regard to how
this general algorithm is a little bit
different than if just running
reinforcement learning with a recurrent
policy
any thoughts on how it is different
so there's a few answers in the chat
i said we don't use the predicted
actions
as the d train is fixed i'm not quite
sure what you're suggesting
um said each time step is not dependent
on the previous step state
but all previous steps
um so this is pretty close to one of the
one of the things that i was going to
suggest
um
suggest that the reward can be different
from test time so this is one of the
differences is that you're actually
going to be training this recurrent
policy across multiple different mdps
with different reward functions
um and this reward function is kind of
passed as input to the policy which is a
bit different than how you would
typically use a recurrent policy
and then i guess getting to what was
saying about each time step not being
dependent just on the previous step
state but all previous steps
the other core thing that's different
about this policy is that
the hidden state of your current neural
network is actually maintained across
episodes
within a task
so typically if you were to train a
recurrent policy you would just kind of
roll out that that recurrent network
throughout that episode and then when
you start a new episode you restart the
hidden state but in this case because we
want to learn across multiple episodes
we want to actually kind of maintain
what we've learned across those episodes
rather than completely resetting the
hidden state
what this looks like is
say that we
um kind of have episodes of length
capital t
then we're going to be rolling out this
policy
for t time steps
right here
then
keep on maintaining this hidden state
across the episode boundary and
we continue rolling out that policy to
be able to learn across multiple
episodes
so this is kind of episode one this is
episode two and so forth
and then
if you then want to start learning a new
task then
that's that's kind of the only time when
you'll reset reset the hidden state
and start learning again for that new
task
uh so it's asking if you restart the
hidden state how does the model learn
um
so the model is able to learn
like within a task so you don't reset
the hidden state within that task
because it needs to be able to learn how
to solve that task across episodes you
only reset the hidden state when you're
trying to then learn a new task
so
this would be like
i don't know task i
this might be
task j
this is asking do we start with d
trained or are we making a d train from
the intermediate actions outputted by
each model and constantly generating new
trajectories from the model
so
yeah so the
typical the kind of the way that you can
view this
is we are constantly adding to d train
and at each time step
um
for example when we're
when we're right at the beginning winner
right here d train just corresponds to
s1 0 a1 and r1
um and then later on over here d train
corresponds to all of your experience so
far throughout this trajectory
um there are situations there are well i
guess we'll get into this later but
there are situations where you may just
you may add to d train kind of
incrementally um you just add one
trajectory then another directory rather
than adding them step by step but for
these approaches you're basically adding
to drain it every single time step
okay
so concretely the this is sort of like
what the model looks like what the
algorithm looks like is we sample a task
we then roll out this policy
um
for end episodes which is n episodes is
the budget that we have to learn the
task
incrementally adding to d train as we go
this would be under the dynamics and the
reward for the tasks that we sampled
then we
potentially store that sequence of
episodes in a replay buffer for this
particular task
and then we update our policy to
maximize the discounted return for all
of the tasks in our replay buffer
um
and then you can kind of repeat this
process
uh and note that when you're rolling out
this policy you're actually
optimizing
not just like for return after a fixed
data set size but you're optimizing for
the return
across the full learning process
so in many ways in many ways you're
optimizing actually for
regret um you're optimizing for kind of
not just for return after a fixed amount
of data but for return
as you're exploring
and this allows you to optimize
end-to-end both for very efficient
exploration
and good exploitation of that data
and you're optimizing for kind of a good
trade-off between exploration and
exploitation
okay questions about how this algorithm
works
good question so um someone's asking
what does a rollout mean this is
actually a term that i didn't quite
understand when i was learning things so
by rollout i just mean a trajectory
so
um it's basically a way to say that you
are kind of
rolling out the policy or you're um
incrementally selecting actions from the
policy executing that action in the
environment and so forth um so basically
just corresponds to a trajectory from
that is
acquired by
executing a certain policy
okay so you can also think of this as
like execute for example
execute the policy for um and episodes
you get some trajectory and you store
that trajectory of episodes in your
replay buffer
yeah and then asking what is it like for
meta testing
at meta testing you're given a new task
and
you can basically just like it basically
just corresponds to these first two
steps here where you're given a task and
you just
roll out or execute the policy that you
have where you're incrementally adding
to your
training data
it's asking how does this algorithm
encourage exploration
so
the
i guess there's a few different points
here so
there's exploration at the middle level
and also exploration within a task
one way that it will encourage
exploration within a task is that
say for example
um
maybe say say for example you're in the
amazing environment that we had before
and you get a reward if you go here
and you're kind of you start right here
and maybe there are some walls
and so forth
that make it uh kind of non-trivial to
get to the reward actually
you should remove that last one um
and so this is going to encourage
exploration because
if for example different tasks have
rewards in different positions so maybe
this one looks like this
this maze
looks something like this then in
different tasks in order to for this
policy to get rewards within a task it
needs to be able to execute actions that
allow it to identify where the rewards
are
and this policy
at the top can basically encapsulate
both
the exploration process and the process
of actually exploiting that
uh and
this recurrent policy won't actually be
successful at getting good rewards
unless it has actually sufficiently
explored its environment to find where
the rewards are
um there's also exploration at the meta
level
as well
um and you need to actually be able to
kind of
find um find a good strategy for
learning and find a good strategy for
finding rewards
this that sort of exploration at the
middle level really comes down to the
objective that you're using for updating
the policy
and here kind of standard approaches for
exploration can be used to try to
incentivize different kinds of uh
approaches
so he's asking why can't we use this
algorithm for standard rl as well
this algorithm written out here requires
that you have
multiple different tasks
i guess in principle you could also
apply this to a single task where you're
optimizing for a good trade-off between
exploration and exploitation
for that single task
however if you just do it for a single
task then through this process you'll
learn a good strategy for the task and
you'll learn a good way to exploit and
get lots of rewards for that task
and then like if you're given kind of at
meta test time given the same task
then uh
then it doesn't make sense to explore
again for that same task because you've
already learned a good strategy for
solving that task
okay
so
what do
one thing i want to touch on is like how
do you actually instantiate this
algorithm with different architectures
and optimizers
i'll highlight a few
common approaches so
one common approach is to use some sort
of rnn like architecture like we were
just talking about
and this might include things like
an lstm
or a gru
and then again you're kind of rolling
this out across episodes and then the
way that you could optimize this for
current policy
might be with
something like trust region policy
optimization which is a policy radiate
method
or
a3c which is
asynchronous advantage actor critic i
believe um
the takeaway here is that both these
approaches are on policy approaches
um
and kind of are updating this policy
with the current the latest experience
that it collected
uh and this was summarized by these two
works right here which were
two of the works that used
some of the kind of the first works that
showed with modern deep neural networks
and deep reinforcement learning
algorithms that you can learn how to
learn
for things like navigation tasks and and
other tasks
also the first author of the second
paper jane wong is going to be giving a
guest lecture in a couple weeks and
she'll be talking about a kind of a
cognitive science perspective on meta
reinforcement learning
so this is kind of a basic approach that
you could use
um
one paper followed up on these and
instead of using an rnn architecture
they use a architecture that uses
attention uh it actually interleaved
attention and 1d convolutions
we actually included this as a as an
example of an architecture for the meta
supervised learning problem as well uh
and this paper actually showed results
for both meta supervised learning and
meta reinforcement
um
this is before things like transformers
existed but you could also use things
like transformers and other like
attention-based architectures to
integrate your previous experience
and then the last example that i'll
mention is uh this architecture right
here
um the way that this architecture looks
is it is actually a feed forward
architecture where it passes transitions
into
a
single feed forward neural network and
then integrates
integrates those to produce a single
context z
or single kind of
embedding z
based on
this
context here
and then this kind of
this embedding of the task is passed to
the q function in the policy
and they use a q learning like method uh
in particular a method called soft actor
critic
to optimize for
the tasks
and this method is is
off policy
in the sense that they're able to store
data in a replay buffer and
recall those experiences to train the
the policy and the key function
okay um you might ask well
why would you use a feed forward
architecture if there's all this kind of
temporal structure
one thing that is nice about this feed
forward architecture is that is a lot
more efficient because it's really easy
to paralyze feed forward calls to a
neural network whereas with a recurrent
neural network you have to process the
data sequentially which ends up being
computationally a lot slower
okay
um so now that we've introduced the
algorithm in different kinds of
architectures
i want to go through a couple different
examples of how these algorithms have
been applied
so the first is the maze navigation
example
that i mentioned
and also before i go there there's a
kind of a quick clarification on the
previous one
that's asking the subscripts are our
episodes
in the bottom diagram of slide 19.
um
so
in this case that these subscripts are
actually corresponding to transitions so
it
they sample a number of different
transitions these transitions may come
from
different episodes or some of them may
come from the same episode you can
either use an online variant or an
episodic variant
okay so
for the maze navigation setting that i
introduced previously um this is
basically exactly the experiment that a
couple papers have looked at including
this paper called a simple neural
attentive metal learner
and what they did is they did
metatrading on a thousand different
small mazes
where they were trying to learn how to
quickly navigate in all these different
mazes
and then
they tested on held out small mazes and
held out large mazes
with the goal of seeing if they can
learn to navigate in these new mazes
with a very small amount of experience
in those mazes
uh and the results look something like
this so this is
after the meta training process
so what it's doing here is exploring the
maze
to
figure out where
the goal is
so this is the first episode at meta
test time
and it finds where the goal is and then
in the second episode at meta test time
it's able to go directly
to the goal
so it's kind of
yeah learned how to explore in a single
episode then after that episode it can
exploit that strategy to go directly to
the goal
um here's another example in a larger
maze uh and actually to clarify the
policy only gets this first person
viewpoint as input not the right that
the write is useful for
um for visualization purposes
here's the first episode of meta
training time or at meta test time
where it's exploring and then after that
exploration ape episode
it's able to go directly to the goal
cool and then they also had some
quantitative results where they compared
this architecture that uses attention
and convolutions to an architecture that
uses an lstm
and here they're looking at the um
they're looking at the the average time
to find the goal
within each of the two episodes
so
and then this this up here is showing
like a random policy
and first you can see that the time to
find the goal decreases from episode one
to episode two which suggests that it's
able to learn from episode one to more
quickly find the goal
and second they find that this kind of
attention-based architecture is better
able to
learn from data than in lstm
there's also a question in the chat
that's asking can we speed up the
learning uh of the goal with some
heuristics
uh in general you could imagine having
like adding some heuristics
to the
um to the process
however it's a little bit
tricky to do that
in these visual navigation settings um
it's easy to do that for if for example
you had like this low dimensional
representation of your current state but
if you only have the visual observations
then
it's a bit tricky to try to process
those observations and provide
heuristics because you don't actually
know
your kind of low dimensional 2d position
in the maze
um that said you may be able to kind of
shape the reward function in some way or
something to make
the meta training process faster or
something else
uh asking what is the reward like the
distance at each point in the time from
the goal so
the reward in this case corresponded to
i believe it was kind of a sparse reward
where you received a positive reward
when you were at
the
um when you're at the goal position
and either zero or a small negative
reward if you're not at the goal
position
uh and this makes exploration really
important uh if it's something more like
the negative distance to the goal
then
you don't necessarily need to
you it doesn't require as sophisticated
of an exploration strategy because you
can somewhat greedily act with respect
to that however um
of course even greedy approaches may not
work because there's also walls and
distances may not capture things like
walls
okay
cool so this is the first example
for
these maze navigation tasks
um a second example of tasks is based on
these continuous control problems that
correspond to these simulated robots so
there's this
um this half cheetah robot this humanoid
robot uh this quadruped
and this uh this 2d walker that is
basically a bipedal robot that has two
legs
and different tasks correspond
in different directions running at
different velocities
and
also being able to handle different
physical dynamics like different
friction and so forth
and one of the things that this paper in
particular wanted to study is that
meta reinforcement algorithms are
extremely efficient at learning new
tasks
but
the metatrading process
may not be that efficient
basically the process of learning how to
learn on all the meta training tasks may
require a lot of data
so kind of one
question
um is
would you expect an off policy meta-rl
algorithm
to be more or less efficient than an
on-policy meta-rl algorithm
and recall that an off-policy meta-rl
algorithm
is able to store and reuse data whereas
an on-policy meta-rl algorithm
basically just uses only the data from
the current policy
so you more you could answer in chat um
or or raise your hand if you want uh
more do you think off policy is more or
less efficient than on policymad at
brown
cool so
at least a few people are paying
attention um
and people are saying that it'll be more
efficient to answer the question i mean
the the number of
the number of uh the amount of data
that's needed for metal learning
so
yeah and so the reason why off policy
meta rl is going to be more efficient is
because basically off policy algorithms
can store data in your replay buffer and
keep on leveraging that data whereas on
policy algorithms they need to collect
data collect new data every time your
policy or your meta policy changes
and if you need to collect data every
time your metapolicy changes then you're
not able to reuse any of your previous
data and you have to just keep on
collecting data each time you want to
update your meta policy
okay um and so
here are what some of the results look
like so to unpack this the x axis is
showing the number of the amount of meta
training data
so the amount of data needed for the
meta training process
and the y-axis is showing the average
return
after adapting to one of the tasks in
the task distribution
um and in particular what these
different methods correspond to is perl
is this is an off policy meta rl
algorithm
um
that uses kind of the feed forward
architecture that i showed before
rl squared is
using trpo
and so it's an on policy algorithm and
then these optimization based methods
are also on policy algorithms
and you see a pretty huge gain
by using an off policy meta rl method so
you're able to learn much more
efficiently
um these these dashed lines are showing
the final performance of these three
methods
um so we also actually see a performance
gain in this case uh but the kind of the
main takeaway here is that they're
significantly more efficient
than uh than on policy methods
okay and then it's asking is hindsight
experience replay necessary to make auth
policy more efficient than on policy so
in this case there actually isn't any
relabeling or experience replay or
hindsight experience replay
um
there is uh
you are using a replay buffer which uses
experience replay um an experience
replay is uh
is like something that existed a lot
long before hindsight experience replay
um
if you don't use a replay buffer and
don't replay experiences
then off policy methods won't be more
efficient than on policy um that you'll
both both be operating in this kind of
on-policy setting
okay so those are a couple examples um
for
black box meta oral methods
uh one quick digression uh kind of in
relation to multi-test policies
is that it's
common to do like this sort of multitask
rl where you have some
some information about the task that
corresponds to like
stacking where to stack a lego block or
in what direction to walk
uh and
in this matter oral setting in some ways
you can kind of view this experience as
some context that tells you what the
task is
and
then the kind of the last the last part
of it as your policy
essentially this is kind of you can view
data as another way to express
information or identifiers about the
task
um
we also talked about goal condition
policies before in goal-conditioned rl
and in that setting the task identifier
corresponds to different goals
uh and i guess in this way you can view
meta rl as a strict generalization of
goal condition daryl because rewards are
rewards can express things other than
goal reaching tasks
um although of course you can also apply
it to goal reaching tasks as well
and then the other way to kind of view
this difference between meta-rl and
goal-conditioned rl is that the meta are
all objective your goal is to adapt to
new tasks
versus generalizing to new goals
so it's kind of the difference between
k-shot learning to new tasks and zero
shot generalization
to
a new task given kind of a kind of a low
dimensional identifier of that task
okay so to summarize black box meta rl
uh these approaches are very general and
expressive
there's a variety of design choices for
the architecture
uh the down the kind of downside from
before
is that these architectures can be hard
to optimize because they have to figure
out how to process experience and use
that to learn the task so they have a
pretty hefty task to do
um and then lastly these methods inherit
the sample complexity of the outer rl
optimizer if you use an off policy rl
optimizer that's able to reuse data then
they tend to be a lot more efficient
than if you use an onpaul crl optimizer
okay
cool any questions before we move on to
optimization based meta rl methods
i was wondering if there are any scaling
problems related to how long you enroll
the policy how long the trajectory is
yeah so if you're trying to learn from
kind of a long trajectory
then
the learning problem gets harder
certainly
and especially if you want to
if your task involves exploring in very
sophisticated ways
then it also becomes a lot harder and
we'll talk about the exploration part in
the next lecture
uh
one way to uh to kind of mitigate
long horizons for
um
very long kind of sequences that you're
trying to learn from is to use something
like an attention-based architecture
rather than an rnn
um attention-based architectures
basically allow you to shortcut um
basically these connections between the
orange dots they basically
kind of shortcut the um
short cut
provide shortcuts across time that
directly connect things on the far past
to the present
um and that allows you to handles
potentially some of the optimization
challenges associated with very long
horizon
learning
that makes sense thank you
uh and it's asking why is off policy
more efficient if you store more data
so
the um
the kind of the key thing is that by
storing data and then kind of reusing
that data your model gets to see it gets
to take multiple gradient steps on
a batch of data
whereas in on policy methods you're not
storing any data you're not actually
able to reuse data and learn from it you
basically can just take one gradient
step
on
any batch of data that you have and you
have to kind of keep on throwing away
data
every time you change your policy
and as you might imagine throwing away
data is
leads to kind of pretty inefficient
learning
okay so let's talk a bit about
optimization based meta are all methods
so recall with optimization based metal
learning we're embedding this kind of
optimization procedure or gradient
descent into the learning process
now to turn this into a meta-oral method
the key thing that's going to change is
that
we're going to be running an
optimization on experience from our
policy
and instead of outputting some label
we're going to be outputting an action
from our policy
one thing that's pretty different about
these optimization-based meta-rl methods
is they tend to
well i guess we'll see examples of both
but they tend to lie more in the
episodic variant where you first collect
a few trajectories if you full
trajectories use those full trajectories
to update your policy
and then uh roll out your your executed
roll out your adopted policy
now
one question uh that i have for you
again is what should we use for this
inner
optimization
and you can answer this in chat or by
raising your hand
uh basically we have three options
uh we could use policy gradients we
could use q learning or we could use
model based rl uh does anyone have
thoughts on or suggestions on on
which of these might be a good idea and
why we might consider using that in the
inner loop of a
optimization based meta rl method
also there's no right answer here so um
there's there's pros and cons to both to
all of them
so
is uh is suggesting maybe model based do
you have
kind of
thoughts on why model based might be a
good idea
uh because modelbase can allow you to
have like off policy
uh learning and
uh like we discussed before that of
policy can be efficient
because it helps you to store story
experience
yeah so one kind of benefit of a model
based url approach is that it allows you
to use
off policy data which allows you to be
more data efficient
other thoughts
suggesting policy gradients because then
we only need a few steps in the inner
loop
so this is a good
um
a good suggestion because maybe we would
need
kind of
only a few
steps
and suggesting q learning could use
could work for large state spaces
um
adjusting model base because it takes
into account change in the transition
probabilities
cool so these are some good thoughts
um
for
so i'll start with policy gradients so
policy gradients
um are nice because it's gradient based
and we know that you can kind of um
basically with kind of
uh
the policy gradient looks something like
the sum over time steps
of log pi
times sum over time steps of rt
and basically just with like
with um
which is like one or a few gradient
steps you actually get a lot of
information about the entire trajectory
which is nice
now
one of the downsides of policy gradients
is that they're on policy so they can be
pretty inefficient
another downside is that
policy gradients tend to be pretty noisy
and in particular one thing you might
notice here is that
with this kind of form of the policy
gradient if the reward function
is sparse or not very informative then
this policy gradient isn't going to tell
you that much about the dynamics
or that much about the task
so
say for example you're in the maze
kind of in a maze setting and you start
off right here the goal is right here
and maybe
you have some trajectories that look one
directive looks like this another
trajectory looks like this another
directory looks like this
from these three trajectories you should
have a pretty good idea of like where
the reward is now because you've
basically exhausted all the all of the
kind of paths where it isn't
and so from these three trajectories
you'd love to be able to kind of then
figure out that the next thing you
should do is go over here
however if you have only these three
trajectories
the sum of your rewards is zero because
you haven't experienced where the reward
is and so this policy gradient term is
going to be zero also
and so
because basically just because of this
term being zero
being zero right
and so if you're in the setting where
you have very sparse rewards and you
haven't yet experienced where the task
is you're not going to get any update to
your policy
even though you just had all this rich
information about parts of the
environment where the reward isn't
so this is kind of one of the challenges
with kind of policy gradients is that
they're noisy and they're often
kind of uninformative
uh nothing can't that be somewhat
alleviated by attaching a small negative
reward to every action
uh yes so that can it can be somewhat
alleviated by that um if you instead if
your word function is instead kind of
assigning like a small negative value to
these things or if you have some sort of
baseline that suggests that you should
be able to do better than zero and that
will allow it to push your policy
in the right direction
um
this is kind of one extreme example two
uh even if you have
um rewards that are like small negative
values for example that still doesn't
tell you
um
this this gradient is still fairly kind
of deprived of information about
what the environment looks like and what
the dynamics look like and so forth
okay um so that's policy gradients what
about q learning
so
one of the benefits of q learning is
that it's off policy and so it's very
efficient at learning
um the downside which i think that
it may have been alluding to is that
because q-learning is running dynamic
programming it requires many gradient
steps
so if you look at the bellman equation
for example
um
maybe i'll write it over here your
bellman equation looks something like q
hat minus r
plus uh
gamma max a prime
of q of s prime a prime
and this this right here this is kind of
q hat of s comma a
and basically each gradient step that
you take on this objective you're only
propagating information one time step
from s prime to s
and so as a result if you want to
propagate information throughout your
entire horizon then you need at least
kind of h gradient steps
to really propagate that information
uh and this is a pretty typical this is
a big challenge for optimization based
learning methods where we typically run
only a few gradient steps in the inner
loop
all right so this is one of the
challenges with q learning
and then with model based rl
it's
both off policy like was mentioned
it's also gradient based model learning
just directly corresponds to supervised
learning
so
this makes it also pretty easy to
combine with optimization based metal
learning
so both of these are quite nice
there are scenarios where model based rl
is
difficult um because like learning a
model is hard but in settings where
model-based url works well
we'd also expect optimization-based
meta-rl to be a pretty good option
okay
so here are just some of the general
trade-offs in terms of combining
different kinds of
optimizations with uh
optimization based metal learning
now let's go into a few examples and in
particular we're going to look at an
example of
um mammal with policy gradients and
mammal with model based rl
um
there actually aren't
really any papers that look at something
directly like mammal with q learning
because of this this challenge right
here
um there are a couple papers that
suggest kind of different alternatives
for potentially alleviating this uh but
they're really um
they're they're challenging i guess um
if you're interested in kind of looking
more into this
one paper that you could look at is by
um
by eric mitchell
at all
is called
well the name of the method is called
macaw
not quite a kind of mammal but close
and it's using a kind of advantage
weighted actor critic algorithm um
and combining that with mammal
okay so let's look at a couple examples
so if we combine mammal with policy
gradients um this will just be like a
really simple example
uh like i mentioned before combining
mammal with policy gradients has some
challenges
uh
and this is actually just the example
that was in the original mammal paper
that illustrates one of the things that
you can do with it
and in particular we'll have just two
different tasks here
one task will be
just kind of going left
and the other task will correspond to
going right
and first we'll visualize what the
policy parameters look like after the
meta learning process but before
adapting to one of the tasks
so this looks like something like this
where essentially the policy is
running in place it's kind of ready to
run
in
one of the two directions
and then if we
take a grade one gradient step with
respect to the task of running backward
we get a policy that looks like this
and if we take one gradient step with
respect to the task of running forward
we get a policy that looks like this
so this is an illustration of how with
policy gradients um i think these these
are worth 20 trajectories used to
compute the policy gradient you can
actually get a pretty drastic change of
performance
which is
nice and these are both with shape
reward functions which make it a little
bit easier to handle the noise in the
policy gradient
okay and then let's look at one more
example with mammal plus a model based
rl approach
and in this case we're actually going to
be looking at the online variant of
meta-url where our data corresponds to k
different time steps from
some policy
and so what this will look like is that
meta test time we're going to be
adapting the parameters of our model
to the last k time steps and this will
be with regard to
the error of
kind of f of s a
minus the true next state
so we're basically going to be running
gradient descent on this objective to
update our model
and then once we compute our updated
model
for that
current time step
we then plan
a sequence of actions using our adapted
model
and this will be kind of
with respect to some task reward
uh which may be different uh for
different tasks
uh and then at mediterranean time we're
actually gonna be in a scenario where
the task may actually vary uh
within an episode even but we're gonna
assume that
the dynamics for example are constant
within within kind of a short period of
time but then it may change within a
longer episode
and essentially
different tasks are going to correspond
to different windows in time
where
this kind of window right here will
correspond to what we're wanting to
adapt to which is the last k time steps
and then this window right here which is
kind of the next h time steps will
correspond to our test set
and
we can construct many different tasks by
essentially sampling
a point in time and sampling these kind
of train set and test that windows
uh and this is assuming that the tasks
are kind of
you that the tests only change or the
dynamics only change sparsely in time
but it's still fine if um
yeah it's still kind of reasonably if
reasonable if for example the dynamics
change here um you're only going to have
a few tasks that are sampled within with
the task changing in the middle of it
and most of the windows will be kind of
at different parts of at different
points in time where you have a
consistent task
like maybe um
this corresponds to like running on
grass and this corresponds to
running on
asphalt
then we're going to have different
dynamics for these two different parts
of the environment
and
when we sample tasks that correspond
like right to this boundary those tasks
are going to be pretty noisy because
we're going to be trying to adapt to
asphalt
when we're given data from grass but
everywhere else when we sample all these
windows we'll get kind of valid
parts of a single task
okay so in terms of the algorithm we
basically sample these train sets and
test sets from different windows of time
we use
mammal to adapt our dynamics model on
the train set evaluate it on the test
set
and then update the initial parameters
such that that adaptation was successful
okay so how does this actually look like
in practice so we can look at some
environments that are as i mentioned
before dynamically changing in time
and if we first start with just a single
model based url approach where we're
trying to fit a single model
to varying
with dynamics that maybe actually be
varying across time
this isn't very successful
so in this first example one of the legs
becomes crippled
and a single model isn't able to capture
the dynamics
of a normal leg and a crippled leg
in the second example
these different panels have different
buoyancy kind of like if you're on a
dock
and a single model has struggles to
capture
the dynamics when you're walking on
these different parts of a dock
and so the the agent ends up kind of
flipping over and is unable to kind of
get to
the goal which is kind of
over here basically
now instead if we use um
we use mammal with model based url like
i mentioned before
what these can do is they can actually
adapt
online to the latest k time steps and
continuously replan using the adapted
dynamics model to successfully make it
over to the right hand side of the
screen
so basically here at every time step the
model is being adapted with a gradient
step and then we're running planning
with regard to that adapted model
now one of the cool things that was
mentioned before is that model-based rl
methods are really efficient right
because they can use lots of off-policy
data and so if you compare these
approaches
shown in green
these are both kind of model-based url
approaches where this this dark green
approach corresponds to kind of
mammal plus model based oral
this approach here corresponds to
basically an rnn
based metal earner plus model based rl
both of these are like much more
efficient than these model free
approaches shown in red and yellow
uh and that means that it's actually
potentially practical to run these auto
real robot
so you can collect data
on different terrains with this little
six-legged robot these robots are
actually built by hand and their
dynamics vary significantly across
different frames and across different
conditions of the environment
you can collect data like this meta
train your model on these different
windows of time
and then evaluate how well it can handle
new situations
so in this first case the goal is to
walk up this
narrow slope and the goal is to follow
you'll like walk along a straight line
if you just train a single model across
all the different terrains and so forth
that model struggles to capture the
different situations including this test
situation and the robot ends up veering
off to the right
whereas if you kind of continuously
adapt your model to the different
situations is able to figure out a good
model for
this sloped terrain and uh and follow it
a straight line
um
then you have one more example you can
take off like the front right leg of the
robot
uh
again the kind of the model that was
trained across all the different
terrains
struggles to handle this situation
understandably
uh but if you adapt your model
to kind of the previous windows of time
it could actually adapt to this new new
condition
and walk in a straight line
asking how do we figure out
if the terrain has changed do we have a
fixed horizon we plan and then replan
again
so uh in all of these experiments it's
actually
resetting to the initial model
parameters and adapting the model at
every single time step so it's just
assuming that the model is might have
changed at every single time step and
with that adapted model it's also
replanning at every single time step
because these models are kind of
relatively because the state is
relatively low dimensional and the model
is kind of just a couple layer neural
network
it's pretty fast to run a gradient step
um and therefore it's feasible to run
this replanning in real time
uh if you had like a much larger model
then it may be a lot more expensive
i'm asking where is the reward signal
coming from i'm at a test time so in the
case of the simulated experiments the
goal was just to move as far to the
right as possible so i think the reward
function was something like negative
um it may have been something like
actually forward velocity for example
um in this case
there are actually motion capture
markers on the robot that allow the
robot to know where in the room it is
and then the reward function corresponds
to
basically like a negative distance to
some waypoint which may be at the end of
the line
okay i'm
asking are we training at test time so
in this case the kind of the model is
kind of being adapted at test time with
like one gradient step to go from
f theta to
f by t and this is
this kind of
happens with a
single gradient step
on kind of the model error
on kind of the last k time steps
um this is the only training that we're
doing though
okay
cool
um
yeah and this should be d train because
this is kind of what we're adapting to
at meta test time so this is the
training set at meta test time
okay so to summarize um black box black
box methods are general and expressive
there's a variety of design choices
they're hard to optimize in the meta
oral setting as well as of course in the
original meta learning setting
um in the meta oral setting optimization
based metaurl methods
have the inductive bias of optimization
built in they're easy to combine with
policy gradients and model based methods
with the caveats that i mentioned about
policy gradients before
um
of policy grades being very noisy
they are also hard to combine with
value-based rl methods
because you have to run a lot of
gradient steps in the inner loop to get
signal across your horizon
so these are very similar pros and cons
to before
with kind of some added challenges with
if you want to apply things if you want
to apply optimization based federal
methods
and then both of them inherit the sample
efficiency of the outer rl optimizer if
you use a model based approach it's
extremely efficient you use an offline
approach it's a lot more efficient than
fully on policy approach
um
and the efficiency isn't necessarily
because it's kind of more dominated by
this outer oral optimizer than the
meta-rl approach itself
okay um so
that's it uh
so kind of
we got through the lecture goals and
hopefully that gave you a kind of a
decent understanding of the meta rl
problem statement and the basics of
black box and optimization based meta rl
algorithms
um
as i mentioned before next time we'll be
talking about how we learn how to
explore
so in all of the examples we gave before
we had relatively shaped words it was
relatively easy to figure out how to
adapt to the task
um
or we were able to learn exploration
strategies end to end
in the navigation example
and on monday we'll talk about
situations where
we need to explore in much more
sophisticated ways in order to solve the
tasks
and then on next wednesday uh carol will
be talking about a bayesian perspective
on meta-rl and how we can derive some of
these algorithms from kind of first
principles of from probabilistic
graphical models
um cool and then after that we'll be
talking about more advanced topics like
hierarchical rl lifelong learning and
will also have a guest lecture from jane
wong who will be talking about a
cognitive science perspective on metal
learning
uh hello i have a question regarding the
optimization based on material
okay we'll go back two steps i guess two
slides yes
yep
so uh say if the
like for the other optimization based if
your inner optimization horizon is
pretty long that means you have to
perform multiple even many like green
steps in your inner loop and how does
that affect your gradient with stress
with respect to the outer loop in terms
of noise and also computation
yeah so
for um if you have a very long horizon
uh
like a very long episode for example
if you have a value-based draw method
you need to take many gradient steps but
if you have a policy gradient method
you don't necessarily need to take a
large number of gradient steps um
because the policy gradient is able to
capture kind of information about the
entire trajectory because like we
mentioned it looks something like
like uh
grad log pi
times the sum of rewards so this
contains a kind of like information
about the full trajectory
so in this case it's actually fine to
take one or a few gradient steps even
for long episodes
um but for value based on all methods
it's a big challenge and
uh very few methods have been able to
kind of overcome this challenge
okay and one more clarification is
just for the manual structure in general
like regardless if it's rl or ml it's
generally not a good idea to take many
steps in the inner loop is that correct
um i think the main downside is that it
tends to be
more computationally expensive to take a
large number of inner gradient steps
because then you have to back propagate
through that path
um if you have enough compute then it's
not too much of an issue uh
and
yeah if you if you have a lot like
plenty of compute that is not a huge
issue you can also run into challenges
though where
um
where you're basically
the same kind of challenges when you
train rnns where you get like exploit
ingredients or vanish ingredients
um
that can also be a challenge although
uh usually the computational bottlenecks
are more of a challenge than the
ingredient
okay
i have a quick question we have
the
example we covered snails in the main
example that's very similar to the other
than we implemented in homo and right
i was wondering how that's exactly uh
meta rl uh and how it's different from
conventional order
yeah so
it is um it's basically like very
similar to the approach that you
implemented before the key difference
from
from kind of standard rl is that you are
training it across multiple mdps
and
the hidden state is um
is maintained across episodes within a
task
and so you're allowing the kind of the
algorithm to kind of learn across these
episodes
um
yeah that's kind of the main gist of it
okay and i have a couple one more quick
question uh maybe two so how would i
tell you i have zero honor background
how is modern-based honors different
from policy grading
yeah so model based rl algorithms
are um
so
policy gradient you get a um
basically the way that you update your
policy is with something like
gradlog pi
times some of the rewards
uh and then with a model based method so
this is you just like how directly
update your policy with the model based
method like we talked about in the
lecture
on monday you
train a model train like a neural
network to model your
dynamics and potentially your reward and
then you use this learned model to
update your policy
or to plan actions
and what is inductive bias and uh uh i
think it was like 56 or something yeah i
guess what i meant by that is this
you're building kind of the structure of
gradient descent inside the inside the
optimizer
um
rather than just like completely
training an rnn from scratch to learn
to learn completely um without any kind
of structure of learning or optimization
and one more thing you had something
called zero shot you're going back
i was wondering if you if you if a k
shot was a zero shot i was only if you
knew what that was
yeah so what i meant by that is that um
basically
when you're given kind of when you're
trying to learn from experience
uh you're kind of trying to learn from k
data points and so you're doing k shot
learning
uh
where k is greater than zero
uh and then
in goal conditioned rl when you're just
trying to generalize to new things
you're given a task identifier that
describes something about the task like
the goal that you're trying to reach and
you're not given any data
and so in that sense kind of you can
view k as being equal to zero
and you're giving it information like
the goal
and that's why it's referred to as like
zero shot generalization because you're
not given any experience but you're
still trying to generalize to a new task
yeah so
one question is now um is it you is it
usual to incorporate important sampling
when you try to do weather aisle
um i guess there's a few different parts
that you could imagine using important
sampling if you're using policy
gradients that's kind of a reasonable
reasonable approach to
um
to try to allow it to use off policy
data to some
degree um so one paper that does
something like this is
called guided meta policy search
um
that use kind of importance weights in
the
outer loop to allow kind of a policy
gradient method to use a little bit of
off policy data
um
[Music]
i don't know of other approaches that do
it in the meta learning literature
yeah
also
in the whole
paper the efficient of policymaker our
paper
um during meta test term you don't
update a policy
but only in further um i guess the
context which
is like a
task identifier right
yep
um
so what's the reason behind not updating
the policy during meta test time
yeah so it can be viewed just like
another black box meta rl method where
you're basically just kind of taking
data
as input so
all of this data here is referred to as
c in in the paper but you can do this as
d train
and we're taking d trade as input and
producing some kind of
low dimensional embedding of d train
that corresponds to z
and this z is passed into the policy in
the q function
and so you can view the z as kind of
allowing it to take in data and adapt to
that data
okay um if that's the case would it
wouldn't be a bit more helpful to
separate the influence of
the environment and the task done
you try to it's for example if you have
a different
um state space for each task then
you have to like if you want to have
them to share some common structure then
you have to like um
use a part of the girl states as like a
reduced dimension
um of the girls base i mean the state
base to
incorporate information
information from different tasks and
use an additional environment identify
yeah so if your mdps are varying in
different ways then you can imagine
potentially having like
one encoder that tries to like
summarize
information about the
about like the dynamics
and then like one thing
that tries to summarize information
about the reward
and then you could pass like one of
those into into these um okay
the pearl paper didn't do anything like
this and
i don't know of any papers that does
this but it does seem like something
like this could be helpful especially if
you know
that some tasks share a reward function
but just have different dynamics and
other tasks like only shared dynamic
like you have other tasks share the
reward but have different dynamics
yeah cool
so um just one last question and
um it's about the memorization paper
so in the inner loop of coming
when you calculate the um general
ascension error bands within each task
um that one is upper bounded by the
generalized station error error
of the like the
just the
metal parameter
but it makes sense to use that
actually use the for example count
divergence between the
updated um
task specific parameter and the prior to
determine the learning rate and that
kind of stuff
right um
so
[Music]
let's see
so i guess for to write things out um
maybe just pick a random slide the um
what that bound is looking at is it's
looking at basically like
the generalization error it's saying
that this generalization error is
bounded by
or uh
yeah and then you're measuring yeah plus
referring to the tailbone yeah
yeah it's like something like this
this is from memory but
something like q of theta
times
by p of theta um and then there's some
other stuff
yeah over here um
and you're basically saying that if this
kl
is uh
uh no that's that's two part of the
equation there like um you found
generalization error um to the
uh
expected task error and the expected
house error is also bounded by the
empirical area
and
um like i'm saying if you can separate
those two bounds and use um
the tail you're written on the slide to
bound the meta test i might comment the
parameter but the other character to
bound the updated
parameter
like in the way you um
um update it in the in the loop of
mammal for example
yeah potentially um
maybe if you could post a question on
kyoto i think i may be able to to give a
better response
sure thank you
yeah um it's like
i'm still very confused about
black box better reinforcement learning
methods like my understanding is um
is it just as how you explain it to
um the other the other classmate
so
we give
trajectories to this black box um
recurrent structure network and it like
up with some
identifiers or like
some latent
um
vectors some later variables that will
be feed into a
policy gradient or like whatever
um rl methods
that for training is is that what it is
then like um
yes then
do so we still need to like collect data
when we train it with
crm methods and its own policy will
collect new data
yeah exactly so when i when i said
rollout policy here kind of what i meant
is you
collect data with the policy that you
have
okay gotcha that makes sense thank you